George Washington's battle sword
Pablo Martinez very intricate sword but
I'm confident in my skills I'm confident
that I could build a good weapon the
handle is very intricate this is
probably one of the hardest things that
I've ever had to do and we're gonna go
for it
I'm gonna try a different approach to
try to get deeper Fuller in my blade I'm
going to be really careful with this one
I don't want to overheat this thing
worst thing that could possibly have
happened happened
two days gone
I think I clamped it down when it was
still too brittle wow
wow this is a nightmare this is like a
major setback all right I'm gonna make a
sword in one day
I've got a hammer this thing out as
quickly as I can just beast mode I gotta
I gotta get this done